...
-Ne dites pas que ce garçon
était fou.
Il ne vivait pas comme les autres,
c'est tout.
Et pour quelles raisons étranges,
..les gens qui ne sont pas
comme nous, ça nous dérange ?
Ne dites pas que ce garçon
ne valait rien.
Il avait choisi un autre chemin.
Et pour quelles raisons étranges,
..les gens qui pensent autrement,
ça nous dérange ?
Ca nous dérange.
Il jouait du piano debout.
C'est peut-être un détail pour vous.
Mais pour moi,
ça veut dire beaucoup.
Ca veut dire qu'il était libre,
heureux d'être là, malgré tout.
Il jouait du piano debout. Quand
les trouillards sont à genoux..
..et les soldats au garde à vous.
Simplement sur ses deux pieds,
il voulait être lui, vous comprenez.
...
Il n'y a que pour sa musique
qu'il était patriote.
Il serait mort au champ d'honneur
pour quelques notes.
Et pour quelles raisons étranges,
..les gens qui tiennent à
leurs rêves, ça nous dérange ?
Lui et son piano,
ils pleuraient quelques fois.
Mais c'est quand les autres
n'étaient pas là.
Et pour quelles raisons bizarres,
..son image a marqué
ma mémoire ?
Ma mémoire.
Il jouait du piano debout.
C'est peut-être un détail..
..pour vous. Mais pour moi,
ça veut dire beaucoup.
Ca veut dire qu'il était..
..libre, heureux d'être là,
malgré tout. Il jouait du piano..
..debout. Il chantait
sur des rythmes fous.
Et pour moi, ça veut dire beaucoup.
Ca veut dire essaie de vivre.
Essaie d'être heureux,
ça vaut le coup.
...
Il jouait du piano debout.
C'est peut-être un détail pour vous.
Mais pour moi,
ça veut dire beaucoup.
Ca veut dire..
..qu'il était libre,
heureux d'être là,
..malgré tout.
Il jouait du piano debout.
Quand les trouillards
sont à genoux..
..et les soldats
au garde à vous.
Simplement sur ses deux pieds,
il voulait être lui, vous comprenez.
...
Il jouait du piano debout.